A couple years ago, I was able to raise $2
million dollars for my startup, all because
of a single tweet.
There are plenty of entrepreneurs who can
raise money quickly because they already know
all the big VCs, but this was cold outreach
to an investor I’d never met before.
But I knew this would work, because I was
using a three step framework that is pretty
much guaranteed to get you a meeting with
a VC if executed properly.
Fundraising is often confusing and frustrating
for early stage entrepreneurs, but it doesn’t
have to be.
Follow the steps outlined in this video, and
you will be having pitch meetings with plenty
of venture capitalists in no time.
I’ve raised money 10 different times now,
and even though each time was slightly different,
every successful fundraise follows this same
fundamental pattern.
Today, I’m going to tell you how I raised
$2 million dollars for my company using Twitter.
It’s a pretty funny story actually.
So, without further ado, here’s the tweet
that brought in $2 million dollars.
If it looks underwhelming, that’s because
it was designed to be.
A venture capitalist had tweeted about some
research they were doing and I simply replied
saying that they missed one important piece
of the puzzle and I could help them.
Even though that tweet is only 17 words, there’s
actually a lot going on there.
So let’s break it down and work through
what you need to do as an entrepreneur to
win the attention of venture capitalists.
Everyone thinks that they need to be a massive
influencer in order to leverage platforms
like Twitter to raise money, but that’s
just not true.
Most entrepreneurs are far too busy to grow
a serious following on social media and in
an odd twist, growing a massive following
can actually hurt your credibility.
There’s a great saying that goes: “The
rhetorical style of any Twitter account that
continues to gain followers converges on that
of a fortune cookie.” and I’ve certainly
seen this in practice.
Endless growth requires endlessly broadening
your appeal, but that leads to a kind of “lowest
common denominator” type of content that
anyone can understand.
Entrepreneurs need to be experts in their
field, and if you’re working on something
truly new and disruptive, there’s a good
chance that the industry is extremely small.
Consider crypto at the early stage: Ten years
ago, most of the conversation about Bitcoin
was hosted on small forums and completely
inaccessible to general audiences.
You had to have strong software engineering
chops to even follow basic discussions, but
that was actually a positive signal to investors.
So instead of becoming a “fortune-cookie”
account and constantly tweeting: “work hard
and anything is possible!”
I’ve always focused on talking about complex
topics where I can actually push the conversation
forward, even though my tweets aren’t likely
to go viral anytime soon.
At the time I posted that Tweet, I barely
had a thousand followers, but you could quickly
skim my profile and know that I had experience
in consumer startups, and that was enough
to pass a quick check by someone visiting
my profile and wondering “is this person
legit?”
So before you fundraise, it’s important
to really know your industry inside and out.
You don’t need to be creating loads of content,
but if you’re going to use a particular
platform, it’s good to establish a solid
track record.
And that’s step 1: Become an expert, and
people will want to hear what you have to
say.
There is a great saying that goes: “If you
want to be interesting, be interested.”
- When you’re working on a new idea, you
should be voraciously consuming information
related to that idea.
Sometimes this means taking classes on the
subject, but other times it’s just taking
the time to read books, blog posts, and technical
papers to really understand where the cutting
edge is in your industry.
Once you know your industry cold and are ready
to start networking with venture capitalists,
it’s important to focus on finding “founder
- VC fit”.
A lot of entrepreneurs get caught up chasing
celebrity investors, but that’s actually
a huge mistake for two main reasons.
The first is obvious: famous investors are
flooded with pitches all day long, so it will
be hard to break through.
But the second reason is actually more important
here: famous investors who don’t know about
your market, or aren’t interested in it,
are likely to be less helpful.
It can be tempting to just look at the Midas
list of top venture capitalists and think
everyone on there would be an incredible addition
to your company, but a VC who’s focused
on biotech may not be able to help, at all,
with a crypto project and vice versa.
You need to focus on finding investors who
have specific experience in your industry.
Look at who’s funding companies that are
like yours and then start to follow and engage
with these folks, instead of just aiming for
whoever has the biggest name.
That’s what I did when I was raising money,
I stumbled upon a Principle at Greycroft Partners
who was hyper focused on direct to consumer
ecommerce companies.
His name was Teddy Citrin and he had only
been in venture for a few years.
He has a sharp eye for ecommerce companies
and new trends, but he’s not exactly a household
name in Silicon Valley, at least not yet.
That didn’t matter though, because I was
focused on founder-VC fit, not strictly big
names.
And this is step 2: engage with investors
who are actually experts in your industry.
When you find investors who are active in
your industry, it can be tempting to try and
pitch them immediately, but coming on too
strong can often be a mistake.
I always think of that scene in Star Wars
where Han Solo is flying past Darth Vader’s
ship:
“Now don’t get jittery, there are a lot
of command ships.
Keep your distance, but don’t look like
you’re trying to keep your distance.
-- I don’t know, fly casual.”
You don’t want to look desperate for funding,
but you also don’t want to look like you’re
hiding the fact that you’re desperate for
funding.
Just “fly casual” and start having actual
conversations with VCs about what’s going
on in your industry.
So that’s what I did.
I started engaging with Teddy on Twitter.
First by reposting some research he had done
on the industry.
He had essentially collected every sub-sector
of the direct-to-consumer ecommerce space
and organized them into a massive Google sheet.
His post had done well on Medium, and certainly
didn’t need me to signal boost it.
But this little shout out put me on his radar.
My tweet only got 3 likes, but one of those
was from him.
So 5 weeks later, I followed up, by replying
to his original post about the spreadsheet
saying: “Loved this post.
There’s one category you missed though.
Happy to chat about it if you’re interested”.
Teddy had clearly spent hours pouring over
industry data, and he definitely thought that
he had considered every possible segment,
but I knew he had missed one critical area
and it happened to be the industry I was currently
trying to disrupt: big tobacco.
My co-founders and I had been grinding on
our new idea, called Lucy, for over a year
at this point, and we knew a lot about the
tobacco industry.
Cigarettes kill millions every year, but the
tobacco industry still generates over one
trillion dollars per year.
That’s right, a trillion.
With a T.
Teddy had outlined dozens of micro industries,
with market sizes as small as $4 billion dollars,
but he had completely missed tobacco.
There was a good reason for this, no startups
had really attacked big tobacco before, so
there wasn’t much buzz in Silicon Valley
about the opportunity.
That was exactly why we liked the idea so
much.
Smoking was a huge problem and solving it
would clearly have a positive impact while
still being a good business.
Now, I could have just said: “Hey, you missed
tobacco, you should add that to your sheet.”
but that strategy would have failed.
Building intrigue is one of the most powerful
communication skills.
I try to do it in every YouTube video I make,
first getting you interested in what I’m
about to discuss before diving into the details.
I knew that anyone who had spent so much time
researching ecommerce companies wouldn’t
be able to resist the opportunity to learn
about a new area they hadn’t considered
before.
This is step 3: build intrigue around what
you’re working on so the investor wants
to learn more.
There’s a reason why murder mysteries are
so popular.
Just open up Netflix and you’ll see dozens
of shows about mysteries.
Humans are hardwired to seek out answers to
unsolved questions.
It’s basic human psychology.
But I didn’t just leave him hanging, I offered
a clear solution.
A way to make his analysis more complete and
learn about the missing category: just chat
with me.
Adding a clear call-to-action there is critical.
Venture Capitalists get flooded with requests
for meetings all day long, and their schedules
are packed with back-to-back calls.
The easiest way to get a meeting is to offer
something of value in return.
Setting time aside for a meeting creates a
cost, so you need to offset that with a benefit.
Every VC knows that most meetings won’t
result in an investment opportunity, these
meetings are risks that they take in order
to find the next great company.
As an entrepreneur, you can offset that risk
by guaranteeing that they will learn something
interesting that they didn’t know before.
Even if the investor winds up passing on the
deal, they leave knowing more than they did
at the start of the meeting, and that’s
valuable to someone whose job it is to understand
markets.
My plan here worked perfectly, I had established
myself as someone knowledgeable in ecommerce,
found an investor who was uniquely interested
in ecommerce, and then piqued their interest
and offered to help them expand their understanding
of ecommerce.
Following these three steps will make cold
outreach to investors way more likely to succeed.
Investors get flooded with pitch decks to
their emails all day long, so you need to
stand out, building relationships slowly and
then leveraging human psychology to ensure
you get a meeting is vastly superior to just
spamming investors and hoping they respond
to you.
When you start fundraising for your business,
it’s useful to think about the process like
a funnel: at the top of the funnel, you have
all the investors who could possibly fund
your business, but you need to narrow that
down to just the investors who would be a
good fit.
Once you have that list, you need to get meetings
with them.
It’s impossible to get an investment out
of every single meeting, even incredible companies
like Facebook and Google had meetings where
investors passed on the opportunity to invest.
So your job is to make sure that when you
reach out to an investor, they take the meeting.
Following this 3 step plan will make sure
that you get those meetings, and don’t waste
your time reaching out to dozens of investors
who just ignore you.
Now, to be fair, when I sent this tweet, I
already had a pretty significant startup experience
under my belt.
I’d co-founded Soylent and raised over $75
million dollars for that business, but I really
think that doesn’t matter all that much.
When I was still in college, I used the same
technique to get in touch with Jim Breyer,
who led the Series A in Facebook and I’d
seen giving a talk at Stanford alongside Mark
Zuckerberg.
In 2012, Breyer and his fund, Accel Partners,
were riding high off of the Facebook investment,
but I was still able to chat with him on Twitter,
just by following his work and sending him
the occasional thoughtful message.
It was super inspiring at the time, and a
big reason why I felt that starting a company
in Silicon Valley would be a great move.
So regardless of your background, if you can
become a true expert in an industry, investors
will want to talk to you.
It’s really that simple.
So get out there and start pitching, but don’t
look like you’re pitching.
You know, pitch casual.
If you want to talk about fundraising strategy
for your startup, just leave me a comment
below or DM me on Twitter, and please check
out this recommended video, the YouTube algorithm
thinks you’ll really like it.